loki was yes a comic book
villain and somebody with magical powers
um and someone who had to these these
emotions had to read on a big scale but
also
if he boiled it down there was something
very very kind of human about his
about the things he was his grievances
thor 2011 directed by kenneth branagh
um four months of auditioning
i think in 2009 a big leap
a big leap for me um from making very
small films
in the uk and working in the theater
and suddenly in
the next marvel studios picture
after iron man it was
it was a moment of adjustment and a
moment it kind of
just i felt like i won the lottery and
it was kind of
it had a the whole thing had a
a very special um atmosphere
i had worked with kenneth branagh
before we had acted together in a
television series on the bbc
called wallander and we had also acted
together
on stage in london in a chekhov play
called ivanov
this was my first time being directed by
him but we had a we had a kind of
understanding as actors and i felt very
grateful to him
that he had it was able to somehow
support
my casting to the studio it was a kind
of amazing
and extraordinary and unprecedented
process of
working on a project of this scale
working with
a stunt department and working with
visual effects
on blue screen and green screen on sets
the size of which i had never seen but i
was a fan of these movies too
and i and it was such a joy for the
first time to be inside the process
but rather like any any process of
making a film
in the end it comes down to um
the atmosphere you create together as
actors and
um trying to tell a story and trying to
tell it with
you know which is interesting and
complex and
sort of recognizable emotion and
hopefully it's funny and it's moving
and it's touching and it it kind of it
connects with people
and i could see from the first script
that the story was really there were two
stories almost one was a
was on this epic
spectacular canvas asgard a shining city
in the sky with a rainbow bridge
and a kind of intergalactic energy that
connected it to other universes
that transported characters to new
worlds and
and this was this was a world of gods
and monsters a world of from myth and
legend
and we knew the film had to deliver on
that scale but inside it was a very
small drama about the family about the
father and two sons
ken brunner sitting us down and saying
actually this is what the film is is
it's about this family
and a father two sons their mother
and they're all sorts of uh fractures
if that happens to be the family um
the royal family at the top of the
universe there's a very very high
stakes but ultimately they'll still have
the same
very relatable very accessible family
dynamics as any as any family on the
planet
and so that became a very interesting
psychological thing to explore about
a triangle of odin and his two sons thor
and loki
and loki's sense of being
marginalized or or less favored than
thor
and why that should be was it just
because he's the younger
brother and therefore won't inherit the
throne and all that responsibility
and then loki finding out halfway
through the film that he's actually
adopted
and wasn't even supposed to be there and
then feeling very betrayed and
and um and upset and
gives way to all kinds of vulnerability
and
and anger and grievance and grief
laughy son
yes
why you were knee-deep in your blood
why would you take me you were an
innocent child no
you took me for a purpose what was it
tell me and that's when he becomes an
antagonist in a way and that's that
thor and loki fragment and split off and
become
adversaries i swear to you mother
that they will pay for what they've done
today
loki
why don't you tell her how you've sent
the destroyer to kill our friends to
kill me
what why it must have been enforcing
father's last command
you're a talented liar brother always
have been
it's good to have you back and all of
that was really rich
material um to to get into
especially with these actors you know i
remember that
day that loki finds out
he's adopted and it's a scene in the
weapons vault
and it was a just
really it was a very small scene in
terms of its
kind of structure and on the day
kenneth branagh and anthony hopkins and
i was there going oh my god
working with kenneth branagh and anthony
hopkins
[Music]
and i remember also remember them kind
of not able to
talk to each other about how much they
admired each other so they came to me
which is quite sweet
and anthony hopkins telling me how much
he admired kenneth banner and kenneth
spider tell me how much he might answer
hop because i felt i was like a vessel
for their
um for their kind of uh sheepishness
about
about being able to be honest about that
um
but it was a big day and it was a big
day of big emotion and
and um and i remember that scene became
the anchor for the whole
characterization
you know it all makes sense now why you
favored thor
all these years because no matter how
much you claim to love me
you can never have a frost giant sitting
on the throne of asgard
loki was yes a comic book
villain and somebody with magical powers
um and someone who had to these these
emotions had to read on a big scale but
also
if he boiled it down there was something
very very kind of human about his
about the things he was his grievances
and last but not least
my first film with chris hemsworth with
whom i made a very fast and
and and firm friendship because we
playing brothers in this enormous thing
and
and uh it felt like we were brothers by
the end
in some way he was the only other person
who understood
what the experience had been like he was
the only other person who i came back
and
friends of mine were like how was it and
i was always hard to explain and there's
one person who knows and it was chris
and
and we've always shared that really
because it's a
it's kind of a life-changing moment for
both of us
[Music]
avengers the first one 2012
and it was the first big team up
superhero film
and i remember reading the script and i
was thinking okay there are six of them
iron man thor captain america black
widow
hulk and hawkeye and there's one of me
and the way this film is structured is
the avengers have to win and we all want
to root for the avengers
and it was so brilliant because it was
almost at loki's
loki's superpower which is his mercurial
shape-shifting
and his capacity to manipulate
situations his wit his charm
his sort of strategic intelligence
is used to turn these individual
characters against each other
um initially so that he has the upper
hand and then in the second act
they actually all unite as a team to
stop him
and i remember thinking i've got to
really lean into my
i've got to really lean into being a
pure antagonist
in this one um because the balance of
the film needs to be such that
you just need loki loki needs to yeah i
wanted the audience to cheer at the end
when
he gets hulk smashed and i think they
did
[Music]
anyway
you are all of you beneath me i am a god
you
dull creature and i will not be bullied
by that
puny god
[Music]
it was it was an amazing experience
because it was the first one and i think
there was a sense of with robert and
chris hemsworth and chris evans
that they were kind of almost relieved
to share the responsibility
for carrying the film and and a kind of
uncertainty about whether we could all
pull it off
when i guess the following spring in
2012 when the film came out and it kind
of became what it became we were all so
honoured i guess we were so honored that
it seemed to work and it seemed to
connect and
and that was a very special experience
to share with them
because the avengers suddenly
took occupied a position in the culture
which they went on to you know they
carried on to the second film and the
third film and
the avengers are this team that
everybody in the world has heard of and
i was really i was really honored that i
was there kind of for the first
the first go-around and they were all so
kind and it was a it was a fun team to
be around and what i've been amazed by
is because i had a little break from
the mcu for a bit while it expanded and
it seemed to get
the mcu seemed to get braver and the
film seemed to get bigger and more
ambitious and with doctor strange and
black panther
and the the characters from wakanda
and ant-man and the guardians of the
galaxy and i
and i was sort of watching from the
sidelines going
i'm so proud of all these actors and
what they're doing this is great
watching with my popcorn on the opening
night and um it was really fun to just
feel a part of it in some way
um and then it kind of culminates with
infinity war and uh an end game where
you see
all these individual films and the
threads of the infinity stones it all
kind of crystallizes in
and in this moment of of all the
avengers against thanos and
it was just such an extraordinary
experience to be a part of
[Music]
the rightful king of the ottenheim god
of
mischief do hereby pledge to you
my undying fidelity
[Music]
what i was used to say was like taika
took
everything that had been built before
and just added all of his own
kind of sense of humor and style and
um the bells and the whistles and you
know there were fireworks and
he kind of that he he was able to
respect what had gone before
and say but this is my reading and
it was so playful and so irreverent it
was just so fresh and he
first my first conversation with taika
was um
look three movies and
loki's always somehow manages to you
know pull the wool over thor's eyes
and get him to trust him and then betray
him what if
thor was on to him what if what if thor
wasn't gonna be fooled you know
fooled again and it was actually loki
who was on the back foot
and so thor's you know like okay loki
i get it you get me to trust you then
you betray me
fine you can keep playing the same tune
if you like i'm gonna go off and do this
and loki is almost non-plussed by that
it's like what
so the shtick isn't working anymore i'm
gonna have to think of something else
and um and that was really new so so
in a way like loki becomes the straight
man and
and thor becomes like off and thor's
playing off that
um and loki has to think of like another
way
a sort of a way of reinventing himself
because it isn't working
and there's a great scene where loki
they sort of need each other to get out
of the palace um
the grand masters palace uh played by
jeff goldblum
and um it works for a while and they
form this kind of unstable alliance and
then loki betrays him again
and then thor goes it's not gonna work
like that and then thor betrays loki
and then sort of stands over him and
says you know you just
he just never changed do you just the
same over and over again
and loki is so shocked by it i know i've
betrayed you many times before but this
time it's truly nothing personal the
reward for your capture
will set me up nicely everyone for
sentiment were
easier to let it burn i agree
yeah it was just fun to kind of to send
up
some of the things that i had played
with such sincerity
in the previous films and taika is you
know he comes from a
you know background of independent
filmmaking and comedy and he improvised
a lot
and i was really aware on that set of of
how
kind of bonkers and funny this film is
going to be and and
chris was so released as well by because
i mean everybody knows by now but chris
is hilarious
and he he always has been um
ever since i met him and he was kind of
like he felt so free
because thor was kind of silly and you
know
there was a lot of uh a very endearing
very endearing goofiness to what he was
doing
just joining in in that atmosphere was
was really fun
and also that finally it sort of sets
him on a road to
to kind of maybe setting down
some of the old tricks and some of the
old ways of doing things and
and reflecting and thinking well maybe
you know
if i can't provoke my brother anymore
maybe i should
join him i really enjoyed that that
ultimately
the the death of his father and the
threat to his home
he's like you know i'm going to miss who
am i without thor
i'm going to if thor is destroyed and
asgard is destroyed
i don't know who i am so maybe i should
be there i should help them
i think it's really touching i hope in a
very unsentimental way
i mean you didn't think i'd really come
and see you did it this place is
disgusting
does this mean you don't want my help i
couldn't jeopardize my position with the
grand master took me time to win his
trust
he's a lunatic but he can be amenable
what i'm telling you is you could join
me at the grand master site
perhaps in time an accident befalls the
grand master and then
[Music]
what i love about loki the series is
it's the loki you know
in a world you don't know this is the
loki who's mischievous and witty
and charismatic and playful
and transgressive and disruptive and
broken and vulnerable
and angry and betrayed and jealous and
fractured
and all these things the whole cocktail
someone who you can't trust
ever the trickster but he's always
someone who's somehow been in control
and he's suddenly in a world where he
has no control
he's in a institution a bureaucracy
called
the tva the time variance authority and
they are an organization who have been
tasked with
the order of time reality unfolds
as it should according to its
predetermined decisions
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this is absurd
sign this too
and loki is a character who basically
inhabits the idea of chaos
and he's up against a bureaucratic
institution that inhabits the idea of
order
and you put those two together
and that's where we start so
therein lies the drama you picked up the
tesseract breaking reality
i want you to help us fix it
why me i need your unique low-key
perspective
do i get a weapon yeah it is adorable
that you think you could possibly
manipulate me
and i love that about him so suddenly
you strip loki of all the familiar stuff
asgard thor green gold
helmets magic it's all gone and you put
him in a world where he's
out of his comfort zone and destabilized
and completely confused and
it's i really enjoyed seeing how
he's almost confronted with having to
find a new way through
and i hope that um everyone is as
excited by as i was
only love is left alive jem jamish
tilda swinton mia vashikovska john hurt
anton yelchin jeffrey wright
i was so um
surprised and delighted to be asked to
be involved
in this jim had been writing a film
for for a while i think for about um
five or six maybe seven years it was
really a film about
a long-term relationship and that the
two people in that relationship
happened to be vampires and so
if you've made a commitment to be with
someone
with one person for the rest of your
life
but the rest of your life is forever
how does that change your commitment and
um
gem and tilde had
our long-term long-time friends and
collaborators
and um and he had very much written the
part of eve
with tilde in mind and he just needed to
find his adam
and i remember meeting jim in uh in new
york he just kind of pitched me the film
he was like so there's adam and eve
and they're vampires but they're
vegetarians
um and uh you know they they said they
have like a deal with a doctor at a
hospital who can get them the right
blood you know and they really like the
good quality stuff and
it was just so it was such an amazing
idea
anyway and he said you know adam is like
he's an
artist and he's a musician and he's
um he's younger than eve eve is like
2000 years old
and adam is only 500 years old but
they're together and they love each
other
but adam lives in detroit and eve lives
in tangier
and it's kind of sometimes they spend
time apart because he likes to go and
make music on his own and
and um and he's kind of
unhappy he's inclined to the sort of the
the
the heaviness the spiritual heaviness of
of the romantics a pure romantic
somebody who feels everything
and can um maybe perhaps he's even a
little bit depressed
and he feels um kind of burdened by the
weight of the world on his shoulders and
and that you know that life is unfolding
reality and
and things happening on earth are not
going well and
and he has a heavy heart um but it's a
pure one and it's an honest one and it's
kind of got this
this quite childlike sensitivity and eve
is much wider
and deeper and broader and that she can
contain
him i think it's called only love is
left alive for a reason it really is
about love and
the power of real love and the endurance
and durability of it and how strong it
is if it's real
and that true love is about acceptance
and accepting somebody else for
everything they are and and they're both
artists they both have this appreciation
for
for literature and art and music and and
the finest things and i learned a lot
not just about filmmaking from both jim
and tilda
um but also just about life there's an
amazing line
that uh eve
says to adam when he's feeling a bit low
and and and she and
and she needs to kind of pull him out of
his
of of the place he's at in his mind and
she says
how can you have lived for so long
and still not get it
this self-obsession it's a waste
of living
that could be spent on
surviving things appreciating nature
nurturing kindness and friendship
and dancing
and as advice goes i don't know if you
can get better than that
um and then they put a record on and
it's um
denise lassal the record called trapped
by a thing called love and
and they dance and they smile and they
fall into each other's arms and they
just thought
it's yeah it's a it's a very close it's
a project that's very close to my heart
that one
for all kinds of reasons yeah
crimson peak guillermo del toro
this was you know again it kind of came
out of nowhere
i suddenly got a call um
saying you know i was i think i was in
north america anyway and they said could
you fly to
toronto next weekend to meet guillermo
del toro and i was like sure
and i got on a plane and i met guillermo
and
he kind of met me straight off the i
arrived at the studio straight off the
plane and
and um we sat down and had a cup of
coffee or something and
he pitched me this film a gothic romance
in the manner of the great gothic
romance novels of english literature
jane eyre the mysteries of udolpho by
anne radcliffe
he mentioned bluebeard this there was a
trope essentially in literature
at a certain time where a young
and pure-hearted heroine would meet a
tall dark stranger
who lived in a big house on the hill and
they would fall in love and and then it
turns out the tall dark stranger was not
as pure-hearted as
perhaps she first thought and maybe
there are some skeletons in
in the closet or in the basement and
this was kind of a a kind of a
um a literary trope in
in in that time and he wanted to use
that to make a
a version of that sort of film but with
a with a different sort of ending
the ghosts rather than being somehow
metaphorical
would be would be real and that he'd be
using the same
techniques and craft and makeup to to
bring these
these ghosts from the past to life that
he had used in
in his other films um particularly
patton's labyrinth
and the devil's backbone and it had a
much more actually quite a feminist
inclination you know the the heroine
played by
mia vashikovska my second time working
with mia
after only love is left alive she
absolutely takes charge of her destiny
in this
good morning miss forgive the
interruption
i have an appointment with mr carter
everett cushing goodness with the great
man himself i'm afraid
sir thomas sharp aaron
he'll be here shortly thank you you're
not
late are you he hates that uh not at all
in fact i'm a little early oh i'm afraid
he hates that too
the film is about edith's agency and um
i play the tall dark stranger who at
first appears to be
elegant and charming and full of promise
and and
kind-heartedness and there's a few
secrets in his past
and and a sister that uh hasn't been
accounted for
played by jessica chastain guillermo's
knowledge
of his craft of the world of literature
of the world of gothic romance of cinema
of acting
of filmmaking is encyclopedic
and simply being a part of his crew
um was was like was such a pleasure
and a privilege because he knows pretty
much how to do every single job
and his kind of authority over his
vision
is total and the attention to detail the
precision with which he works
he understood that you know
people do things for the reasons they
have and perhaps they're not aware of
them but sometimes you know
characters make bad choices but there's
always a kind of emotional logic
so thomas sharp a baronet
somebody who had inherited this
crumbling mansion
um on on a hill in northern england
um who seems to be one thing and then is
revealed to be
another and the one thing that's that's
um
people may know about working with
guillermo is he he writes
very long and detailed biographies of
each character
so when you're working with guillermo
he'll he submits you with
a typed um almost novella
of your character's life before the film
starts
so you have this whole biography a whole
integrated psychology i think what the
reason you know
the reason he's like this is because
this happened when he was a child and he
was sent away to this
you know to this aunt he lived on the
coast and she didn't make nice food and
she was abusive and all these kind of
details which were so informative
what do you think does it look the part
it does although it's even colder inside
than out
i know it's a disgrace we try to
maintain the house as best we can but
with the cold and the rain it's
impossible to stop the damp and
erosion and also that set
whiz uh i remember we were in a studio
in toronto
and alladale hall is the mansion that
the sharps
live in and he built a set that was on
three or four stories i think it's one
of the biggest
sound stages in north america so we had
to be there to fit this set inside it
and so that when you go upstairs you
would actually go upstairs and you when
you walked along the landing you could
play
if somebody was was on the ground floor
somebody could be on the third floor
landing and you play these
it was like a real house and there was
one
detail i remember that the the plaster
of the wallpaper was cracking and
if you looked closely the cracks in the
plaster spelt out
a word and the word was fear
and he said no one's ever going to catch
that on camera
i just want you to know that it's there
i thought
this guy is just you know where do you
get that you know
it was it was a really interesting
journey to play
that kind of archetype
from gothic romance yeah
archipelago written and directed by the
great joanna hogg
who really i owe everything to she was
the first director who who gave me a job
when i left drama school
it was a an extraordinary
first film for me because joanna
almost invented for herself a new way of
working which was to take
a script which had a story which went
from
a to z or a to z and she decided to film
it
or shoot it chronologically and most
movies and films are shot out of
sequence and the
actor's job is to know where you are in
the story because you
you know each piece of jigsaw puzzle
isn't in sequence whereas this was going
to be we're going to start at the
beginning
and finish at the end and we
lived through the make the story in
sequence
and we improvised even though the
the order of the scenes was the same we
actually improvise within
the structure of the scene and it can
run for very long takes and very wide
shots
an archipelago is a collection of small
islands
scattered in a body of water and
they are the archipelago in the film is
the isles of silly or the silly isles
which are about 25 miles off the coast
of
cornwall in the uk um so very far
south on the way into the atlantic ocean
and the location is where this these
older children edward is one of them are
they're going off for one last family
holiday
but you realize that the family itself
is an archipelago
and each member of the family is an
island
in a group scattered in a body of water
and they're not quite connecting
all the actors live in the house where
the characters live
and it's interesting i think the effect
is one of
you start to do things authentically
and do things on camera in a very
unaffected way so if a character goes to
make some eggs or make a cup of coffee
or a cup of tea
because you're actually living there all
the time you do it you're almost not
acting it anymore and
and similarly in a very unusual way
we started at the beginning and we
improvised our way through
the whole story it was kind of an
extraordinary
tuition in the honesty of film acting
which i owe to joanna because she she
loved the naturalism of
the way real life is it gave me a lot of
insight into the kind of
um discipline that actors have to have
about
the truthfulness of what they're doing i
would one night to see her before i go
uh before i go away for 11 months i
don't know what's going to happen
and um you can split up no we're not
going to split up
i don't know i don't know what we're
going to do i mean it actually frankly
would have been nice to have had her
here with us now i don't really see why
she couldn't have come
she couldn't really come here could she
because it was like a family holiday
edward in archipelago was
was almost the first in a line of
characters of people who felt
which is look i can only tell looking
back is
characters who felt that they were
somehow misunderstood or
slightly isolated within their own
family and it was quite strange because
i remember shooting archipelago
just before i went to los angeles to
start making the first thor film
and there were these strange connections
i started making between edward and loki
which were they're both siblings and
they both feel misunderstood by their
parents and
they're completely different films um i
mean the idea of loki turning up in
archipelago is
a puzzling one um or the idea of edward
turning up in thor with a kind of
a scarf blowing in the wind you know
it's kind of
fished out of water but um weirdly i was
i was kind of playing in the same
territory psychologically which is an
interesting
thing at the time the deep blue sea
we made it in the late fall early winter
of 2010 directed by terence davis
and starring rachel weiss and simon
russell beale
and it's based on a play
by terence ratigan is a very moving
portrait of
a um a woman who
is trying to leave a very fragmented
marriage and moving into
a an affair with a younger man in in
in london in the 1950s in the wake of
the second world war
and she falls in love with a
a young bomber pilot called freddie page
who i played
she feels slightly stranded between two
men who offer her different things
it's really a film about unrequited love
and
and um or or the ways in which we
misunderstand each other in our attempts
to love terence davis is a very poetic
british filmmaker and i found terence
very
sensitive and caring and kind and
his knowledge of the perspectives of
these three people he was very
attentive to both to rachel and to simon
and to myself and understood that
there really are no villains characters
singing in pubs is almost a signature
piece for terrence davies because he
remembers
in as a child growing up in liverpool
that in those years after
britain was a not an easy place to be
because
so many of the cities had been ravaged
by the second world war
and communities have been diminished and
and
the economy had taken such a hit and the
50s were quite hard people to get
through but he remembers as a child
at a certain time of night walking past
the
local pubs and people would go to the
pub and they would sing
together as a group act and so it almost
in
in the terence davis thing to have
people singing in pubs
and i loved that aspect of the filming
they're seeing a
joe stafford song called you belong to
[Music]
me
and i think in the film if i remember it
it blends into them
dancing together and having a very very
close intimate moment which is almost
about the poignancy of being alive
they're so they're so happy to be alive
and i think freddie is so
feels so privileged that he's one of
he was one of his number in the royal
air force
to come back and he's made it out
and to your second point i think that's
why he's so angry
is because there's a moment where hester
rachel's character
makes an attempt on her own life which
is unsuccessful
and freddie is so enraged that
she could be so careless with with life
but he also doesn't have the sensitivity
to
contain her anxiety in that moment and
in that use in his anger you suddenly
see all of his
war trauma that actually hasn't been
hasn't been able to unpack
i know that i'm going to die
just accept but it isn't your fault it
really isn't freddy
you can't help who you are i can't help
what i am
well i'm not carrying the can for this
old darling no dice
i'm not the villain of the piece no one
is saying you are
haven't you read what i wrote i'm not
blaming you
i was the one who wanted to wait for the
divorce you didn't
you jumped that particular fence now i
never gave myself a big build-up you
knew exactly what you were getting
yes i knew the risk i was taking and i
took it oh my god